let me pull out an old differential
equations textbook that i learned from
in college
and let's turn to this funny little
exercise in here that asks the reader to
compute
e to the power a t where a we're told is
going to be a matrix
and the insinuation seems to be that the
result will also be a matrix
it then offers several examples for what
you might plug in for a
now taken out of context putting a
matrix into an exponent like this
probably seems like total nonsense but
what it refers to is an extremely
beautiful operation
and the reason it shows up in this book
is that it's useful it's used to solve a
very important class of differential
equations
in turn given that the universe is often
written in the language of differential
equations
you see this pop up in physics all the
time too especially in quantum mechanics
where matrix exponents are littered
throughout the place they play a
particularly prominent role
this has a lot to do with schrodinger's
equation which we'll touch on a bit
later
and it may also help in understanding
your romantic relationships but
again all in due time
a big part of the reason i want to cover
this topic is that there is an extremely
nice way to visualize
what matrix exponents are actually doing
using flow that not a lot of people seem
to talk about
but for the bulk of this chapter let's
start by laying out what exactly the
operation
is and see if we can get a feel for what
kinds of problems it helps us to solve
the first thing you should know is that
this is not some bizarre way to multiply
the constant e
by itself multiple times you would be
right to call that nonsense
the actual definition is related to a
certain infinite polynomial for
describing real number powers of e
what we call its taylor series for
example if i took the number 2 and
plugged it into this polynomial
then as you add more and more terms each
of which looks like some power of 2
divided by some factorial
the sum approaches a number near 7.389
and this number is precisely e times e
if you increment this input by one then
somewhat miraculously no matter where
you started from
the effect on the output is always to
multiply it by another factor of e
for reasons that you're going to see in
a bit mathematicians became interested
in plugging all kinds of things into
this polynomial
things like complex numbers and for our
purposes today matrices
even when those objects do not
immediately make sense as exponents
what some authors do is give this
infinite polynomial the name
x when you plug in more exotic inputs
it's a gentle nod to the connection that
this has to exponential functions in the
case of real numbers
even though obviously these inputs don't
make sense as exponents
however an equally common convention is
to give a much less gentle nod to the
connection and just abbreviate the whole
thing as e to the power of whatever
object you're plugging in
whether that's a complex number or a
matrix or all sorts of more exotic
objects
so while this equation is a theorem for
real numbers it's a definition for more
exotic inputs
cynically you could call this a blatant
abuse of notation
more charitably you might view it as an
example of the beautiful cycle between
discovery and invention in math
in either case plugging in a matrix even
to a polynomial might seem a little
strange
so let's be clear on what we mean here
the matrix has to have the same number
of rows and columns
that way you can multiply it by itself
according to the usual rules of matrix
multiplication
this is what we mean by squaring it
similarly if you were to take
that result and then multiply it by the
original matrix again
this is what we mean by cubing the
matrix
[Music]
if you carry on like this you can take
any whole number power of a matrix it's
perfectly sensible
in this context powers still mean
exactly what you would expect
repeated multiplication
each term in this polynomial is scaled
by 1 divided by some factorial
and with matrices all that means is that
you multiply each component by that
number
likewise it always makes sense to add
together two matrices this is something
that you again do
term by term the astute among you might
ask how sensible it is to take this out
to infinity
which would be a great question one that
i'm largely going to postpone the answer
to
but i can show you one pretty fun
example here now
take this 2x2 matrix that has negative
pi and pi
sitting off its diagonal entries let's
see what the sum gives
the first term is the identity matrix
this is actually what we mean by
definition when we raise a matrix to the
zeroth power
then we add the matrix itself which
gives us the pi off the diagonal terms
and then add half of the matrix squared
and continuing on i'll have the computer
keep
adding more and more terms each of which
requires taking one more matrix product
to get the new power
and then adding it to a running tally
and as it keeps going
it seems to be approaching a stable
value which is around negative 1
times the identity matrix in this sense
we say the infinite sum
equals that negative identity by the end
of this video my hope is that this
particular fact
comes to make total sense to you for any
of you familiar with euler's famous
identity
this is essentially the matrix version
of that it turns out that
in general no matter what matrix you
start with as you add more and more
terms
you eventually approach some stable
value though
sometimes it can take quite a while
before you get there
just seeing the definition like this in
isolation
raises all kinds of questions most
notably
why would mathematicians and physicists
be interested in torturing their poor
matrices this way
what problems are they trying to solve
and if you're anything like me
a new operation is only satisfying when
you have a clear view
of what it's trying to do some sense of
how to predict the output based on the
input before you actually crunch the
numbers
how on earth could you have predicted
that the matrix with pi off the
diagonals
results in a negative identity matrix
like this
often in math you should view the
definition not as a starting point but
as a target
contrary to the structure of textbooks
mathematicians do not start by making
definitions
and then listing a lot of theorems and
proving them and then showing some
examples
the process of discovering math
typically goes the other way around
they start by chewing on specific
problems and then generalizing those
problems
then coming up with constructs that
might be helpful in those general cases
and only then do you write down a new
definition or
extend an old one as to what sorts of
specific examples might motivate matrix
exponents
two come to mind one involving
relationships and the other quantum
mechanics
let's start with relationships
suppose we have two lovers let's call
them romeo and juliet
and let's let x represent juliet's love
for romeo
and y represent his love for her both of
which are going to be values that change
with time
this is an example that we actually
touched on in chapter one it's based on
a steven strogatz article
but it's okay if you didn't see that the
way their relationship works is that the
rate at which juliet's love for romeo
changes
the derivative of this value is equal to
negative one
times romeo's love for her so in other
words
when romeo is expressing cool
disinterest that's when juliet's
feelings actually increase
whereas if he becomes too infatuated her
interest will start to fade
romeo on the other hand is the opposite
the rate of change of his
love is equal to the size of juliet's
love
so while juliet is mad at him his
affections tend to decrease
whereas if she loves him that's when his
feelings grow
of course neither one of these numbers
is holding still
as romeo's love increases in response to
juliet
her equation continues to apply and
drives her love down
both of these equations always apply
from each infinitesimal point in time to
the next
so every slight change to one value
immediately influences the rate of
change of the other
this is a system of differential
equations it's a puzzle
where your challenge is to find explicit
functions for x of t
and y of t that make both of these
expressions true
now as systems of differential equations
go this one is on the simpler side
enough so that many calculus students
could probably just guess at an answer
but keep in mind it's not enough to find
some pair of functions that makes this
true
if you want to actually predict where
romeo and juliet end up after some
starting point
you have to make sure that your
functions match the initial set of
conditions
at time t equals 0. more to the point
our actual goal today is to
systematically solve more general
versions of this equation
without guessing and checking and it's
that question that leads us to matrix
exponents
very often when you have multiple
changing values like this
it's helpful to package them together as
coordinates of a single point in a
higher dimensional space
so for romeo and juliet think of their
relationship as a point in a 2d space
the x-coordinate capturing juliet's
feelings
and the y coordinate capturing romeos
sometimes it's helpful to picture this
state as an arrow from the origin
other times just as a point all that
really matters is that it encodes two
numbers
and moving forward we'll be writing that
as a column vector
and of course this is all a function of
time
you might picture the rate of change of
this state the thing that packages
together the derivative of x
and the derivative of y as a kind of
velocity vector
in this state space something that tugs
at our point in some direction
and with some magnitude that indicates
how quickly it's changing
remember the rule here is that the rate
of change of x
is negative y and the rate of change of
y is
x set up as vectors like this we could
rewrite the right hand side of this
equation
as a product of this matrix with the
original vector
x y the top row encodes juliet's rule
and the bottom row encodes romeo's rule
so what we have here is a differential
equation telling us that the rate of
change of some vector
is equal to a certain matrix times
itself
in a moment we'll talk about how matrix
exponentiation solves this kind of
equation
but before that let me show you a
simpler way that we can solve this
particular system
one that uses pure geometry and it helps
set the stage for visualizing matrix
exponents
a bit later this matrix from our system
is a 90 degree rotation matrix
for any of you rusty on how to think
about matrices as transformations
there's a video all about it on this
channel a series really
the basic idea is that when you multiply
a matrix by the vector 1
0 it pulls out the first column
and similarly if you multiply it by 0 1
that pulls out the second column what
this means is that when you look at a
matrix
you can read its columns as telling you
what it does to these two vectors
known as the basis vectors the way it
acts on any other vector
is a result of scaling and adding these
two basis results
by that vector's coordinates so looking
back at the matrix from our system
notice how from its columns we can tell
it takes the first basis vector to 0 1
and the second to negative 1 0 hence why
i'm calling it the 90 degree rotation
matrix
what it means for our equation is that
it's saying wherever romeo and juliet
are
in this state space their rate of change
has to look like a 90 degree rotation
of this position vector the only way
velocity can permanently be
perpendicular to position like this
is when you rotate around the origin in
circular motion
never growing or shrinking because the
rate of change has no component
in the direction of the position
more specifically since the length of
this velocity vector
equals the length of the position vector
then for each unit of time
the distance that this covers is equal
to one radius's worth of arc length
along
that circle in other words it rotates at
1 radian per unit time
so in particular it would take 2 pi
units of time
to make a full revolution
if you want to describe this kind of
rotation with a formula we can use a
more general rotation matrix
which looks like this again we can read
it in terms of the columns
notice how the first column tells us
that it takes that first basis vector
to cosine of t sine of t
and the second column tells us that it
takes the second basis vector
to negative sine of t cosine of t both
of which
are consistent with rotating by t
radians
so to solve the system if you want to
predict where romeo and juliet end up
after t units of time you can multiply
this matrix
by their initial state the active
viewers among you might also enjoy
taking a moment to pause and confirm
that the explicit formulas you get out
of this for x of t
and y of t really do satisfy the system
of differential equations that we
started with
[Music]
the mathematician in you might wonder if
it's possible to solve not just this
specific system
but equations like it for any other
matrix no matter what its coefficients
to ask this question is to set yourself
up to rediscover matrix exponents
the main goal for today is for you to
understand how this equation
lets you intuitively picture the
operation which we write as e
raised to a matrix and on the flip side
how being able to compute matrix
exponents
lets you explicitly solve this equation
a much less whimsical example is
schrodinger's famous equation
which is the fundamental equation
describing how systems in quantum
mechanics change
over time it looks pretty intimidating
and i mean it's quantum mechanics so of
course it will
but it's actually not that different
from the romeo julia setup
this symbol here refers to a certain
vector it's a vector that packages
together all the information you might
care about in a system
like the various particles positions and
momenta it's analogous to our simpler 2d
vector that encoded all the information
about romeo and juliet
the equation says that the rate at which
this state vector changes
looks like a certain matrix times itself
there are a number of things that make
schrodinger's equation notably more
complicated
but in the back of your mind you might
think of it as a target point that you
and i can build up to
with simpler examples like romeo and
juliet offering more friendly stepping
stones along the way
actually the simplest example which is
tied to ordinary real number powers of e
is the one dimensional case this is when
you have a single changing value
and its rate of change equals some
constant times itself
so the bigger the value the faster it
grows
most people are more comfortable
visualizing this with a graph where the
higher the value of the graph the
steeper its slope
resulting in this ever steepening upward
curve just keep in mind that when we get
to higher dimensional variants
graphs are a lot less helpful this is a
highly important equation in its own
right it's a very powerful concept when
the rate of change of a value
is proportional to the value itself this
is the equation governing things like
compound interest
or the early stages of population growth
before the effects of limited resources
kick in
or the early stages of an epidemic while
most of the population is susceptible
calculus students all learn about how
the derivative of e to the r t
is r times itself in other words
this self-reinforcing growth phenomenon
is the same thing as exponential growth
and e to the rt solves this equation
actually a better way to think about it
is that there are many different
solutions to this equation
one for each initial condition something
like an initial investment size or an
initial population
which we'll just call x naught notice by
the way
how the higher the value for x naught
the higher the initial slope of the
resulting solution
which should make complete sense given
the equation
the function e to the rt is just a
solution when the initial condition
is one but if you multiply by any other
initial condition
you get a new function which still
satisfies this property it still has a
derivative which is r
times itself but this time it starts at
x naught
since e to the 0 is 1. this is worth
highlighting before we generalize to
more dimensions
do not think of the exponential part as
being a solution in and of itself
think of it as something that acts on an
initial condition
in order to give a solution
you see up in the two-dimensional case
when we have a changing vector whose
rate of change is constrained to be some
matrix times itself
what the solution looks like is also an
exponential term
acting on a given initial condition but
the exponential part in that case
will produce a matrix that changes with
time and the initial condition
is a vector in fact you should think of
the definition of matrix exponentiation
as being heavily motivated by making
sure that this fact is true
for example if we look back at the
system that popped up with romeo and
juliet
the claim now is that solutions look
like e raised to this
0 negative 1 1 0 matrix all times time
multiplied by some initial condition but
we've already seen the solution in this
case we know it looks like a rotation
matrix
times the initial condition so let's
take a moment to roll up our sleeves and
compute the exponential term
using the definition that i mentioned at
the start and see if it lines up
remember writing e to the power of a
matrix is a shorthand
a shorthand for plugging it in to this
long infinite polynomial
the taylor series for e to the x
i know it might seem pretty complicated
to do this but trust me
it's very satisfying how this particular
one turns out
if you actually sit down and you compute
successive powers of this matrix
what you'd notice is that they fall into
a cycling pattern every four iterations
[Music]
[Music]
this should make sense given that we
know it's a 90 degree rotation matrix
so when you add together all infinitely
many matrices term by term
each term in the result looks like a
polynomial in t
with some nice cycling pattern in its
coefficients all of them scaled by the
relevant factorial term
those of you who are savvy with taylor
series might be able to recognize
that each one of these components is the
taylor series for either
sine or cosine though in that top right
corner's case it's actually negative
sign
so what we get from the computation is
exactly the rotation matrix we had from
before
to me this is extremely beautiful we
have two
completely different ways of reasoning
about the same system
and they give us the same answer i mean
it's reassuring that they do
but it is wild just how different the
mode of thought is when you're chugging
through this polynomial
versus when you're geometrically
reasoning about what a velocity
perpendicular to a position must imply
hopefully the fact that these line up
inspires a little confidence in the
claim that matrix exponents
really do solve systems like this this
explains the computation we saw at the
start by the way with the matrix that
had
negative pi and pi off the diagonals
producing the negative identity
this expression is exponentiating a 90
degree rotation matrix
times pi which is another way to
describe what the romeo juliet setup
does after pi
units of time as we now know that has
the effect of rotating everything
180 degrees in this state space which is
the same as multiplying by negative one
also for any of you familiar with
imaginary number exponents
this particular example is probably
ringing a ton of bells
it is 100 analogous in fact we could
have framed the entire example where
romeo and juliet's feelings
were packaged into a complex number and
the rate of change of that complex
number
would have been i times itself since
multiplication by i
also acts like a 90 degree rotation the
same exact line of reasoning both
analytic and geometric
would have led to this whole idea that e
to the power i t
describes rotation these are actually
two of many different examples
throughout math and physics
when you find yourself exponentiating
some object which acts as a 90 degree
rotation
times time it shows up with quaternions
or many of the matrices that pop up in
quantum mechanics
in all of these cases we have this
really neat general idea
that if you take some operation that
rotates 90 degrees in some plane
often it's a plane in some high
dimensional space that we can't
visualize
then what we get by exponentiating that
operation times time
is something that generates all other
rotations in that same plane
one of the more complicated variations
on this same theme is schrodinger's
equation
it's not just that this has the
derivative of a state equals some matrix
times that state
form the nature of the relevant matrix
here
is such that the equation also describes
a kind of rotation
though in many applications of
schrodinger's equation it'll be a
rotation in a kind of function space
it's a little more involved though
because typically there's a combination
of many different rotations
it takes time to really dig into this
equation and i would love to do that in
a later chapter
but right now i cannot help but at least
allude to the fact
that this imaginary unit i that sits so
impishly in such a fundamental equation
for all of the universe
is playing basically the same role as
the matrix from our romeo juliet example
what this i communicates is that the
rate of change of a certain state
is in a sense perpendicular to that
state
and hence that the way things have to
evolve over time
will involve a kind of oscillation
but matrix exponentiation can do so much
more than just rotation
you can always visualize these sorts of
differential equations
using a vector field the idea is that
this equation tells us the velocity of a
state
is entirely determined by its position
so what we do is go to every point in
the space
and draw a little vector indicating what
the velocity of a state must be
if it passes through that point for our
type of equation
this means that we go to each point v in
space and we attach the vector
m times v
to intuitively understand how any given
initial condition will evolve
you let it flow along this field with a
velocity always matching
whatever vector it's sitting on at any
given point in time
so if the claim is that solutions to
this equation look like
e to the mt times some initial condition
it means you can visualize what the
matrix e to the mt does
by letting every possible initial
condition flow along this field for t
units of time
the transition from start to finish is
described by whatever matrix pops out
from the computation
for e to the mt in our main example with
the 90 degree rotation matrix
the vector field looks like this and as
we saw e to the mt
describes rotation in that case which
lines up with flow along this field
as another example the more
shakespearean romeo and juliet
might have equations that look a little
more like this where juliet's rule is
symmetric with romeos
and both of them are inclined to get
carried away in response to one
another's feelings
again the way the vector field you're
looking at has been defined is to go to
each point v
in space and attach the vector m times v
this is the pictorial way of saying that
the rate of change of a state
must always equal m times itself
but for this example flow along the
field looks a lot different from how it
did before
if romeo and juliet start off anywhere
in this upper right half of the plane
their feelings will feed off of each
other and they both tend towards
infinity
[Music]
if they're in the other half of the
plane well let's just say that they stay
more true to their capulet and montague
family traditions
so even before you try calculating the
exponential of this particular matrix
you can already have an intuitive sense
for what the answer should look like the
resulting matrix
should describe the transition from time
0 to time t
which if you look at the field seems to
indicate that it will squish
along one diagonal while stretching
along another
getting more extreme as t gets larger
of course all of this is presuming that
e to the mt times an initial condition
actually solves these systems this is
one of those facts that's easiest to
believe when you just work it out
yourself
but i'll run through a quick rough
sketch
write out the full polynomial that
defines e to the mt
and multiply by some initial condition
vector on the right
and then take the derivative of this
with respect to t
because the matrix m is a constant this
just means applying the power rule to
each one of the terms
and that power rule really nicely
cancels out with the factorial terms
[Music]
so what we're left with is an expression
that looks almost identical to what we
had before
except that each term has an extra m
hanging onto it
but this can be factored out to the left
so the derivative of the expression
is m times the original expression and
hence it solves the equation
this actually sweeps under the rug some
details required for bigger
mostly centered around the question of
whether or not this thing actually
converges
but it does give the main idea in the
next chapter i would like to talk more
about the properties that this operation
has
most notably its relationship with
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
which leads us to more concrete ways of
thinking about how you actually carry
out this computation
which otherwise seems insane also
time permitting it might be fun to talk
about what it means to raise e to the
power of the derivative
[Music]
operator
[Music]
you